okie dokie first of all i'm a little
upset that
i came all the way to berlin brought you
meat and mac from your mama mac and
cheese from your mama and i get six
minutes with you
your mama sent you meat and mac what she
said is your favorite dish
ever she sent you mac and cheese it's
warm too
both of them are and she sent you one of
her famous rumors okay
this made my whole situation right now
oh my god thank you so much
this is a real surprise this is awesome
two
customs technically you did you know
what you actually you fed me for the
holidays so thank you so i
owe you one for sure this ain't on me
though
okay it's on the people her baby needed
a home-cooked meal we had to make sure
it was done
i love you i love you too by the way
has miss donna showed laurie how to make
meat and mac yet she needs to know these
things
no i don't know if she has but she
definitely needs to know she definitely
needs to
needs that recipe for sure not yet not
yet i don't think so not yet okay well
lori at least know it's his favorite
learn it really is it really is
michael this was 2019 in november when i
came to visit you guys
in berlin can you wrap your head around
the fact that you know we're now
a year and a half and all these delays
are finally getting
for everybody to see this it's it was
touch and go
not really understanding exactly what
was going to happen you know how long
it was going to push or you know when
exactly it was going to come out
it was a lot of uncertainty but you know
honestly i'm really excited that it
finally like i said it has a home at
amazon
uh people are going to be actually
actually able to watch it and enjoy this
movie
we put so much you know effort blood
sweat and tears
into this project um i'm really looking
forward to people
uh watching this movie
somebody would like to talk to you john
if you're done in there
we need you to get back in the field now
you know we
we know you've gotten in shape for
movies before we've seen the kill
monitor creed all that
what was this like i mean what was the
difference
you know in your routine for this movie
i think the
biggest difference you know me and corey
we really try to train for the role
so depending on like what type of
character i'm playing you know
we kind of let that dictate how we train
a little bit
uh so so so we're not looking the same
in every in every in every role
i think i think for uh john kelly
uh more more military training more uh
close quarter combat training you know
uh wearing the tactical vest
and the boots you know and you know and
and the fatigues and the gear
uh as as we train on certain elements so
i start to you know
you know adapt to uh the type of
physique that kelly
would have um you know obviously the
weight training's still there the
endurance
is still there but in this project
there's a lot of water you know um
stunts in training so being able to do
deep sea
uh military diving training and and
understand how to
you know uh be safe in stressful
underwater situations
that was a lot of the of the workout
regimen on this one also
i'm gonna make it right
[Music]
there's something inside of me that i
can't turn off
the part of me that won't stop for
anything
no remorse well jamie bell said you
almost choked him out for real
yes that was actually very intense and
jamie i am sorry but
to my defense he wanted it okay he came
he told me to keep going and i was like
hey man you're sure at this point
my my axe my forehead my forearm is
actually sore for the next three or four
days my entire forearm was sore from
from choking him out but he's a little
glass he said he had bruises on his neck
for real like
no no he was like sore i mean like
drinking tea his voice was was messed up
but that's why i love that guy he
doesn't
he doesn't stop he is uh you know one of
the best scene partners i've ever had
and i was extremely blessed and lucky to
work with him on this one so
now listen i'm about to expose you here
and i'm about to expose your heart to
everybody because
um i was talking about i have no i have
no heart
you're without remorse
but lauren was telling me earlier um
that
this means so much to her because you
know she was in a place
where her world was upside down and she
didn't think she would ever act again
she just
thought she had to focus on her babies
and and just change her whole life and
she said you came to her
as a friend um about this role
and and about doing this and she just
appreciated the safe space so much
and i'm trying to say this without
crying because it's just really
beautiful
what what made you pour into her like
that
and in this project and and you know
why you did what you did ah i didn't
think
she was even gonna mention that you know
i love lauren lauren is like
my homies you know and a lot you know a
lot of people don't understand that they
don't they don't know that
but like and and what she went through
her strength was inspiring and truly
incredible you know
um nip you know was
somebody that i admired and looked up to
i felt like you know acting sometimes a
release you know and to be able to
express yourself in a way that you
normally
can't in other situations and i felt
like specific to this character and and
their relationship on screen
i felt like it was opportunity that if
she was up to it if she was if she
wanted to
that could be something for her to to to
let some of that
out you know and and and even for me
selfishly as
an actor uh to help me understand what i
was going through
you know as as a character you know so
she
helped me out a lot in this and and and
helped
me wrap my brain around what that felt
like you know and
and and and um and and respectfully how
to
how to how to channel that you know in
in
in a real way so and then i also i mean
we missed her
you know you know we need to see her on
screen that's what i said too
yeah we missed her you know and if this
could could be a start
or you know a place to springboard and
launch her back
into you know what she does so well you
know i wanted i wanted to extend that to
to somebody that i cared about so that's
all you know that was that was
that was it well i'm sure i don't have
to tell you but you definitely did
something for her heart and i think that
really shows your heart that's so
commonplace nah
it's all good man she you know that's
she she's a great
person man and uh you know she deserves
everything that's come my way
don't let america find out that you're
not only cute you got a good heart
too come on man
[Music]
i'll keep your secret i promise
i'm so glad to see your face my man i've
been talking to your mama you know i
gotta check on my girl i've been keeping
no i know thank you so much for that too
she's always mentioning you so thank you
i love her
i love that lady for real like real talk
i love that lady so
i hope to see you soon yes ma'am